um before we talk about the success of
the elizabeth line um are you completely
comfortable with the investigation that
the metropolitan police has done given
the pictures that are all over the front
pages today
well it's very important i explained to
you your views i've been assiduous as
the police and crime commissioner who is
the later politician
not to get involved at all
in an investigation from the met police
into a political opponent it's right and
proper that it's operational
independence but i think the reality is
uh when we police by consent when we
need the confidence of the public when
it comes to policing issues when
questions are being asked about police
investigation and its integrity that the
police explain
some of the conclusions they've reached
i think it's right and probably they do
so
uh yes of course there are big questions
about whether the prime minister misled
the house there clearly was a party he
was raised in his glass their empty wine
bottles uh
will be published in a report later on
this week but i think the police should
be explaining how they reach their
conclusions that's the right thing for
them to do
how surprised are you that he wasn't
fined for that event
well i i want to get into
what's happened all i've seen is a photo
yesterday for the first time and as a
normal citizen forget as a police and
crime commissioner it did beg a number
of questions that's why i think it's
important because many people across the
country will be having similar questions
that they met police explain how they
reach their conclusions they may have
seen other evidence it's for them to
explain so and the reason why it's
important is because we're pleased by
consent we need to have confidence in
our police
the police must police and investigate
without fear or favor but i know from
reading the newspapers today from
watching sky news this morning from
speaking to londoners there are many
questions
they have including to boris johnson to
explain how you can be raised in a class
having emcee boos lying around and not
be a party and at the same time weeks
later tell the house of commons uh there
wasn't a party
yeah we'll move on to crossrail in one
second just a final point on that though
if i may i mean rule breaking law
breaking in your city
should the met come to explain to you as
the mayor of london
why there haven't been more fines in
downing street
well so more than a hundred and twenty
uh fixed pedal notices fires have been
issued
by the police into downing street
parties no other addresses i understand
in a country
has had so much law breaking over the
recent uh past uh i am asking the met
police to provide the urgent clarity i
think they've got to provide not simply
because uh you're asking the question
but people across the country not
unreasonably will be saying hold on a
second
i followed all the rules i was
meticulous in relation to following the
rules those that broke the rules were
fined and here we have a photograph
which looks like uh the prime minister
uh courts red-handed at breaking uh the
rules some would call it
a smoking gun so the police should
explain how it is that more fines
weren't issued that being said it's
really important i make this point
again and again i've not been involved
in investigation there's been
independence it's improper for me as a
political opponent to be telling or
advising or instructing the police what
to do but i think there are legitimate
questions people are asking which is why
i'm asking the police to ride the
clarity
okay um talk to me about the elizabeth
line it's been a long time coming
well listen the first plans for this
particular line were talked about in the
1940s before sky news
first went on uh air the first bill
aborted attempt at 1991
i remember ken livingston the first man
lobbying for this and i gave credit to
tony blair gordon brown for giving the
green light the first bill
uh
went through parliament uh when i first
became an mp 2005 royal ascent 2008 when
i was a transport minister in 2009 the
first construction began in canary wharf
and last week her majesty the queen
formally opened this line named after
her in this platinum jubilee year it's a
remarkable transformative railway line
it's a landmark moment for our city
it'll contribute 42 billion pounds
towards our nation's economy the trains
are built in derby uh the doors for the
stations in cheshire the signage in the
isle of wight the steal from dorset more
than 70 000 jobs already created around
the country i'm proud as the mayor but
also as a brit
but there's a bit of an issue 73 miles
long which is a uh it goes from essex i
believe to berkshire but some problems
with construction at bond street is that
right so you can't actually travel the
whole line in one go until next year
so this this new line today is more than
100 kilometers from reading in berkshire
to shenfield in essex at the moment
you're going to just jump off the train
and get on another train at paddington
uh
and then at liverpool street and that
was always a plan but the good news is
rather than waiting a year as was the
original plan
before that to be fully integrated it'll
happen this autumn as it is in london
often you've got to change from one line
to the other so the dlr you you clock in
clock out the same goes for the waterloo
and city line nothing new there except
what is new is these uh trains are air
conditioned you can walk through the
stations are like cathedrals i'm here at
farringdon where you've got a sideways
lifter going down so look let's enjoy
these 100 kilometers
from the west in reading to the eastern
essex and be proud
of this fantastic engineering feat
sounds amazing looking forward to
traveling on it mr mayor thanks very
much indeed for joining us